hi amanda
how's it going good how are you good
good nice to see you let me start off by
saying wow i mean you are fantastic in
this the way we see you evolve from
elizabeth as a teen to becoming a
self-made billionaire was
i mean it was incredible um
what part of elizabeth's journey was the
most challenging for you to take on i
think the fall
the fall was a little tricky because i
you know i my job as an actor is to find
like all the compassion in the world and
try to figure out this person in their
head and i you know our i had the most
to me i mean liz merryweather is the
most amazing writer she wrote like
it was almost like she was in my head
too
she really got this version of elizabeth
and and i and i really want this version
of elizabeth to be true
because i love this version of elizabeth
holmes but i am i think because i got
close to her and i i really cared about
her and also because i know she just had
a son
and mother from the mother point of view
it's just like i really didn't want to
play
the choices that she made because i
didn't want it to be true and i didn't
want it it was like watching the titanic
thinking that maybe
maybe this time i watch it it won't sink
you know so that was tricky because i
i was a little closer to her than i was
in the beginning and i you know i had to
play these tough these tough parts and
so yeah that was trickier than i
expected
yeah for sure i found it really
interesting though to learn that you
originally passed on the role
and had a change of heart like the next
day what was it about the role
and the series that changed your mind oh
it wasn't even the role or the series
zoo okay i it literally was that it shot
in la
that's
i don't know
i had covered and i was very
upset about having covid
because i was locked in like the
basement of this townhouse that i it
wasn't mine i was in georgia with my
family you know and my baby i was still
breastfeeding and i was like it was just
the worst i don't know
literally it was a geographical decision
right the throws like
alpha variant coveted it's so it's just
the silliest story because
in hindsight of course i was fine but i
was really scared and i was like i'm not
i can never leave the farm again i'm not
shooting in l.a and of course the next
day i was like roll the lifetime let's
do it you know
yeah but i think i didn't know that part
like it changes the game i'm a mom i get
it when you have a baby and then of
course you have like a covid i'm sorry
but yeah of course you would be like
yeah i don't know i'm like life's too
short yeah i know that life's too short
my legs are sweating
because i was like my fever was whatever
it was a girl everybody's got a code
story or two i've had it twice um stop
you have not yet i got omicron as well
from a shoot they're both from shoots i
got them both from photoshoots
it's fine
okay i haven't got it yet i'm not even
gonna say yet i'm just gonna say not
fine you're totally fine no i i'm only
saying that because i have to
yes but um but i will say you know i uh
i'm gonna keep getting those
vaccinations when they tell me to i get
you no i get you i get you so then when
the sweats went away and the baby went
down for a nap you were like i need to
do this
yeah it was the next morning i was like
this is a dream
you know she's an enigma and
yeah we are as a society so fascinated
with this with a rise in a fall and
especially
when she was really smart really
charismatic she had a dream and a
beautiful idea that could have changed
the world absolutely very confident like
so proud of this woman and then and then
um and then it didn't pan out and she
and she had to lie about it and she
didn't have to lie about it but she did
and it's just like
and she's being held accounted
accountable for her for her choices but
you know it's it's she's still an enigma
it's a
we i want to know why i just want to
know why and the documentary in the book
and the
the you know all the journalistic
perspectives have been amazing to open
the door for this but we actually really
at this point were ready for the
microscope to go in to hone in on her
on her uh on the perspective of
from her
angle so i i think this was necessary
for fans of her story and i think this
is actually going to make people
question
their own their judgments in the in the
first place because everybody's i mean
everybody's famous has has some idea
about them but yeah go into the nuance
and the complexity of each each human
being one at a time like we did here
with her
who knows people might
might have a little bit of a change of
heart maybe yeah
interesting okay for you though the
mannerisms of elizabeth you felt were
really important to nail and there were
some that you were not too concerned
about talk a little bit about that
i i um you know i wasn't con
super i know this sounds crazy but i
wasn't super concerned
with how deep i could go because i
needed the audience to stay with me
and if it had to feel
somewhat comfortable
i mean at first you know it's a very
deliberate thing that she did lowering
her voice
um because her affectation or the way
her voice moves and the way
she sounds is more like an accent to me
so that was that was natural then i had
to get comfortable with that but the uh
the lowering of the register was
something that i um it needed it needed
to sound like i wasn't killing myself at
times and
that was tricky and then i and then i
was more concerned with the way she
walked um
where she used her
her mouth
and her neck and the way she didn't
think those were the things that i held
on to and those are the things that i
just kind of let go of um
and i think that i i think we built a
good version of her i think people for
sure can stick with with me they need to
that's the whole point for sure heroes
like i just don't want them to lose
i want them to see elizabeth holmes yeah
within five minutes or else yep not that
night
nah you did a good job listen your
instagram um those animals on your farm
i mean they're adorable filming a series
like this or just living in a time that
we're living right now how important are
these animals to your to your mental
wellness and just your overall happiness
they are everything to my mental health
i keep i keep telling my friends i have
in two two different people in the last
week i've said
just get yourself a flock of chickens
[Music]
once you have to be responsible even for
chickens
really something yes it's perspective
it's like i
there's a reason i go out and i feed
every morning
unless unless i have a meet like a zoom
meeting earlier unless i have to take my
daughter to school i am the morning feed
person i don't care if it's five degrees
i will put on three pairs i do it i know
how to do it and as soon as i get out
there i can only think about the animals
because i have to do what i need to do
and everybody gets something different
and there are so many different kinds
and it's so
like it's the most grounding thing in
the world because they're just animals
you